it is possible to trans-differentiate
their gonad into that of the opposite
sex
[Music]
fun how are we doing this morning
good that's what we like to hear
excellent this is a quite a raucous
title isn't it for like whatever 10
o'clock on it 11 o'clock on a on a
Saturday morning the future of sex why
am I here to talk to you about this
um because it's my favorite subject
basically
um so for those of you who don't know
I'm a molecular biologist which means
that I spend most of my life indoors
hiding away from the Sun and doing
experiments
and why the future of sex well because
um I am lucky enough these days to study
a subject that I find really really
interesting which is to do with how
ovaries are built
um so I study um a process called
primary sex determination lots of things
in Sciences I'm sure you're aware have
these really jargony sounding names but
this one I actually quite like because
sex determination kind of does what it
says on the tin it's about how sex
biological sex is determined so I study
how it is that during embryonic
development an embryo is able to make a
decision that shapes a part of its body
into either becoming ovaries or testes
and in my case why rather ovaries than
testes so I care more about the ovaries
um so again this is a little bit of
basic biology stuff at the beginning I I
I'm sorry for those of you who know this
I like to just remind everyone at the
start of these kinds of conversations
just so that we're all up to speed with
the the basics and then we can get into
the significantly hairier for the lack
of better word uh Parts later on
um
raucous I said
um right so
let's cover the basics everyone in this
room started off Life as a single cell
one single cell
um it happens at the point at which
um your mother's biological mother's egg
and your biological father's met
fertilization happens and why do we care
about this that is the point at which
um the entire totality is something that
we call your genome came into existence
okay it's a collection of DNA
um
basically is the totality of your genome
that comes together so that cell
suddenly has this whole bunch of DNA in
it that tells it what it's going to do
and how it's going to behave and why
it's going to divide and why it's going
to do these various different things
that it's going to do and how you're
going to end up looking the way you look
right now or the way I looked right now
and one of the coolest things about that
point that moment in your life that very
first moment that all the bits of DNA
that are going to help you become you
come together is there's a whole
dedicated book and chapter in that
section that says theoretically you are
going to become male or you are going to
become female so from the point of
fertilization onwards there's a
chromosomal complement it's called you
have sex chromosomes you have a section
of DNA that will theoretically at least
all things being well mean that you are
going to become a male or a female again
a bit of basic biology I'm sure you all
remember this females like myself for
example carry 2x chromosomes I did
actually get myself sequenced I
definitely have two of them so we we
know this for a fact
and that's really interesting I think I
think that in general so before I had
eyes before I had hair the color that I
had before any of those things in that
moment I was a potential human being but
it knew even from that point onwards it
had a set of DNA that was designed to
make me supposedly female
right so then what happens well
embryonic development is really
interesting another thing that I think
is important to mention at this point is
the fact that a cells divide
they all continue to carry that same
genetic component that your genome those
DNA pieces that we're talking about are
found in every single cell in your body
okay so from one cell to several
trillion cells maybe a few Less in my
case because I'm a bit short but you
know
I every single cell in my body has that
same has that same genome in it okay and
as embryos develop they kind of work a
bit like
how I think at least a sculptor may be
sculpt so embryonic development is very
uniform so you and I would have looked
very very similar for the very first few
weeks of development same with any of
the gentlemen in the room as well
everything's kind of the same for the
first eight weeks
and then what happens at that point in
time is this process of primary sex
determination that I talked about that I
study okay so this embryo is kind of
like a rough structure it starts off as
a mass it gets the first thing that you
have to decide if you're building say a
statue of a human being presumably is
which end is going to be the head end
and which end is going to be the leg end
um and what happens is
there's a part of the embryo that is
called a bipotential gonadal ridge which
is a bit of a mouthful but that will
become
because it is by potential either the
testes or the ovaries okay the sort of
the same structure can actually become
one or the other and the thing that
decides whether or not that's going to
happen is the sex chromosomes that I
just mentioned okay so for eight weeks
from the point of conception those sex
chromosomes are sat there and some
recent evidence suggests that there's a
little bit of activity in relation to
those sex chromosomes but the main thing
that they're there for is to wait for
those eight weeks and then to kick into
action and at that point what happens is
if you have a y chromosome which some of
you in this audience do have
um
you have a gene called sry
which kicks into action at that point
and it makes a little protein and it
basically instructs those cells to start
building a testis okay if that doesn't
happen for any reason right if
something's gone wrong with SRI if
anything's gone wrong with any of the
other genes that are involved in this
entire process
that will not happen okay
so I don't know how many of you in the
room have heard about disorders of sex
development dsds intersex these are
things that people are starting to talk
about a lot more in the public
Consciousness and how does that happen
well that happens because of something
that I've just alluded to which is okay
fine you might have these sex
chromosomes to begin with but it's not a
simple process there's many different
genes involved they're all working
together as a team they all have to work
together well as a team to ensure that
not only do do the testes or the ovaries
respectively form but that they they
work properly that they do their job
if any one of those players goes wrong
you can range from having sex reversal
so if you have no sry if that doesn't
happen for example or another Gene which
is very important if that doesn't
activate and do its job properly in
embryos that carry XY chromosomes you
can have something called a sex reversal
and it can be clean it can be a neat
just that's it it now is born looking
like a female everything seems to be
going fine
so humans it's a bit more complicated
than that and it all needs to really
work out really well because
um what we haven't discussed in this
point apart from the fact that I'm
wittering on about my favorite organs in
the in the body is the fact that gonads
so testes and ovaries are really
important because they are the seat of
our future reproductive potential right
that's where these magical cells sit and
wait until their glorious moment comes
at some point probably used to be in our
20s nowadays in our 30s for geriatric
mothers and whatnot and all that kind of
thing but um they wait basically our
gonads testes and ovaries are
effectively like long style long-term
storage devices designed to hold your
germ cells there that's what they're
called the cells that will become either
your sperm or your egg and keep them
ready to go safe away from the
environment ready to go only when
they're required okay
so thinking about when I was talking
about when things can go wrong you can
have some pretty extreme things go wrong
like the the dsds and the sort of
intersex phenotypes that can happen
where you know it can be either a
complete sex reversal or things can go
um not to plan let's put it this way and
you can end up with intermediary uh
statuses between male and female but
also you can end up in a situation where
things only went a little bit wrong and
maybe you don't find out about it until
the day comes that you try and have a
child and it hasn't quite gone to plan
okay
so that's kind of like the basics of
what's happening in general this is what
we understand about about sex and
biological sex I'm sorry to anyone who
came here thinking about this is going
to be about how like the physical sex is
going to be looking in in 20 years time
with robots involved and all that stuff
it's pretty cool but I'm not an expert
in that at all so go somewhere else for
that I'm afraid
um
so
but I am interested in how it is that
we're going to reproduce in the future
like physically like in terms of
will we will we do it naturally or will
we all be having children through IVF
should we shouldn't we all these things
so that's what I'm going to be covering
today
um so let's let's lay into this okay so
this is the basics that I've told you
one of the first conversations I had
with my boss and this is like this is
strapping basically this is really cool
this is one of the first conversations I
had with my boss when I was um taking up
my position
um as a postdoc
um that reminds me as well sorry I
should say this I'm here as myself as an
individual I'm not representing my
institution which is the Francis Crick
Institute so whilst I am employed as a
professional scientist my opinions are
my opinions okay just so you all know
okay so this is the coolest thing I
think I've heard in a very long time
scientists like to do experiments right
and I just told you DNA is really really
important
well how do you know something's really
important like really really important
like if aliens Came From Outer Space
right now okay
and they wanted to know
what are all these things that are that
these human beings seem to be sort of
hovering over are they important how
important are they they might take the
chairs away and see what happens and
would the event be disrupted maybe a
little bit you'd all stand right if the
Wi-Fi in London went off or the
electricity we'd all bloody know about
it wouldn't we and we'd be disrupted
so similarly to that scientists do
experiments where they take out sections
of DNA to ask the question how important
is this piece of DNA
now something I haven't said explicitly
is of course there's DNA which is just
the molecule that our genome is written
in and there's sections of Interest
which are called genes so specific genes
make specific proteins proteins are like
tools that cells can use so we care
about the genes okay so if I take
specific Gene out of an embryo let's say
before it is anything other than a
single cell at the very beginning I take
a gene out
and I say I think this Gene is going to
be really important say for example that
sry Gene that I mentioned sits on the Y
chromosome so if I take that Gene out of
the Genome of an embryo that carries a y
chromosome it no longer has that Gene on
it right in an experimental format the
proof that this Gene is what makes that
Mouse
it's apparently unethical to do these
things in humans
um so we do it in a mouth
this mouth
would therefore according to what I've
just told you not be able to develop
testes right and that's the proof so by
removing things scientists are able to
demonstrate to prove experimentally
something is of importance or not of
importance okay
right so here comes the fun fact
so embryos have these cells they form
these bipotential gonads and then
there's a whole program of genes that
kick into action that tell those genes
and tell those cells excuse me that they
should build a testis
and it used to be the case that we all
thought that once a cell decides what
it's going to do it's made that decision
that's it that's what it's doing
so recent work in other Research
Laboratories
in mice I have to say
have demonstrated that it is actually
possible
to remove DNA genes
from those particular cells that form
the bulk of say the test is and if you
remove one particular Gene of interest
from those cells
they apparently seem to forget that
they're meant to be the cells of a
testis and they transdifferentiate
within the gonad of the adult Mouse
into
the respective building blocks of an
ovary instead and they
transdifferentiate the gonad from being
a test essay into becoming more of an
ovary
now this is not the reception I normally
get so to scientists it's like what are
you talking about hang on a minute like
you also you're like right when when
when's the bomb getting dropped that was
the bomb let me let me just repeat that
so you all understand what I've just
said to you
by removing a single Gene in the gonad
of an adult Mouse it is possible to
trans-differentiate their gonad into
that of the opposite sex and the truth
the the same is there we go thank you
thank you thank you good grief look at
this
um I didn't do any of these experiments
so I shouldn't claim any of the credits
so continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas